[Music]
it's et social study what the stars are
posting online did you know did you know
no Selena Gomez has the best response
when her makeup artist pokes fun about
her type
it's well-known that both ex Justin
Bieber and The Weeknd shared the same
nationality in Canada and Canada you
know Selena love Canadian alright then
there's Dax Shepard and Kristen Bell
enjoying a kid-free night out to see
Hamilton for the first time we're here
at the Richard Rogers theater in our
seats about chocolate covered
blueberries
and the cutest man in town
Kristen shared how Dax hates musicals
but he gives the Broadway show a pretty
good review during intermission what do
you think so far I wish there was more
singing and what would your alternative
title to the show be camel toe because
of outfits
moving on J Lo's twins Max and Emmy are
growing up fast
she posted a pic of her kids in deep
concentration while on their personal
laptops and Carrie Underwood gets her
Zen on with two-year-old son Isaiah the
country singer shared a video practicing
yoga poses with her adorable little boy
in his pajamas he's the best thing near
my husband ever did
[Music]
you